mm my name's parapa and welcome to an
indie horror game so this one's called
vapor it looks pretty [ __ ] cool I'm
not gonna lie like what I saw and they
warned you about epilepsy so if you have
that don't watch this
that looks pretty sweet it's like 3d
okay uh I don't know how I got here
I guess I got from the ocean hmm maybe
I'm a mermaid [ __ ] awesome I always
wanted to be a mermaid we both know I
would be a fabulous mermaid I Trey how
you doing Wow everyone makes out with
Chase it's nothing weird my mom told me
about it she was like that's fine do
whatever you like I don't care anymore
I've given up on you
so hey oh well I don't like this place
and as a mermaid I have my duty to make
out with trees and say the [ __ ] away
from evil skulls
oh there you want all right can I jump
right whoa what happened did something
get sliced off it's another one what do
you want from me it's [ __ ] creepy man
I don't like this what's with all the
shadows what's with all the trees a
little I'm not can't make out with
everyone I should just hide here yes
genius no one will ever find me whoa
what happened what I can shoot mermaid
powers okay let's follow the Sun mermaid
power everywhere
sure whoa whoa whoa I want the mermaid
power away
for the power oh hey why the masa I am
the greatest mermaid this salon has ever
seen what sounds is my main make our oh
I don't know that's a seal uh well [ __ ]
it
there we go what do I do here I'm flying
like that Han wants a high five
I've seen enough hands I want that hey
go grab my ball sir
you're very welcome correct I thought I
was collecting okay so come bus Cologne
whoa [ __ ] off
BAM smack ups mukha there I'm pretty
good I'm pretty proud of myself oh oh
what the [ __ ]
I'm sorry
okay it's [ __ ] creepy man I don't
like this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not gonna make
out with you anymore chase okay just a
little mentally okay fine
just leave me alone I want to go back to
the ocean
oh whatever oh that [ __ ] sound what
the hell did I just no no no no what am
I supposed to do so [ __ ] creepy okay
got it
let's go over here [ __ ] that [ __ ]
huggers I don't hug I'm a mermaid
that's no I I would love a hug from you
though cuz you look beautiful I always
Lincoln way to flirt with my audience
you like it let's be on it oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] on a stick
god dammit I don't want to be here let's
go there shuo job bloody hell Becca's
feet kick slipped up
what don't dog oh are you [ __ ]
serious
Oh No Oh No
what the [ __ ] are you no no no no no no
no no no no no no
Oh doublet patiska feet done I don't
understand what the [ __ ] I'm supposed to
down mermaid power mother [ __ ]
I keep swearing more than men doesn't do
jeah hey get it get it get it get it get
it get it get it
no I go what Joe [ __ ] yo ok yeah we're
just gonna get brownie happy no look
it's a little stone Oh
oh you've done it now pit night-night
madhouse are do for they have a
different purpose
don't know where to go bro dad
bam bam Shazam
hey I'm I don't okay well it's only one
light illuminating oh oh
shap last night victim Victor beat - I
said mixer slicktext cute their latest
sneakers Potter water butter mammoth
will inhale back that spring but open
they're fine but bite we're all fine
this is a normal day in Twitter this is
what we do all the time
what are you there's a light over there
just go go go we're not gonna [ __ ]
die now jump with your [ __ ] mermaid
skills if you need me now you take away
their bit what
nail it I don't know what this is but
I'm taking it hmm I got a sword
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] little
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no I haven't superpowers
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god oh
my god I'm gonna go ahh
don't hide yes guess what now with no
I'm alive oh no never mind we're [ __ ]
health okay no more health fine no big
deal
who wants half anime hey stop slapping
my [ __ ] ass I thought for sure I saw
something over here there you are
don't you dare run away from me go what
is this
so this is kind of like slender I guess
they don't like that they don't like
they don't play games huh you guys go
play again
I
I can't tell whether they might have
Toto I'm so sorry I'm so I hope you
enjoy watching leave a lack up you're
dead I'll see the whatever I'll make
that subscriber come abroad today
thousand breaths and welcome to on an
actual Friday we did it brows with that
I'm proud of you
you don't do [ __ ] but step